here's Joe breeze and Charlie Kelly have
been bombing down trails on mountain
bikes their bikes are state-of-the-art
back and front suspension shock
absorbers precise click shifting and
clipless pedals but it wasn't always
this way and breeze and Kelly would know
they were some of the people who first
developed commercial mountain bikes in
the late 1970s what I had in the 70s was
a goofy hobby that I shared with a few
of my friends like Joe and Gary and some
others that goofy hobby upended the bike
industry assured in a new Olympic sport
and reacquainted Millions with the
simple joy of riding breeze Kelly and
other cyclists in Northern California
began modifying old Paperboy delivery
bikes like this 1941 Schwinn for
off-road use we've discarded the fenders
and the chain garden and got the bike
down to a nice belt 50 pounds some added
front brakes and eventually multiple
gearing they called them clunkers and in
1976 Kelly started organizing races down
the slopes of nearby Mount Tamalpais
on a steep twisting run they called
repack well we were on there's old
coaster brakes at first and by the time
you got to the bottom the grease would
have burnt into a contrail of smoke and
you'd have to go home and repack your
hub hence the name racing was incredibly
hard on the bikes I was breaking a lot
of those frames just seemed like the
price of two or three of those frames
that I was shattering should be enough
to pay for somebody to build me one that
wouldn't shatter so Kelly asked Brees a
bike builder to make him a sturdier
machine from scratch that bike only kind
of a made and it changed the world that
bike Kelly's Breezer number two is on
display at the numeron Museum of
bicycling and mountain bike Hall of Fame
you can see that it has these twin
laterals that go from the head to
down to the rear drop out to try to make
the frame more rigid breeze designed the
bike can be strong enough to handle the
dozens of high speed turns on Mount Tam
and it set off a revolution in bike
design and use the diamond frame really
is the best way to do it but in
retrospect I'm really happy I did those
fun laterals because it makes those
first ten breezers very noticeable word
of this goofy hobby was getting out
first published story February 1978
California by Khizar mountainside
surfing others wanted in on the fun and
they needed bikes too our initial goal
wasn't to make an industry out of this
we were just having fun in the woods
soon mountain bikes were a cottage
industry Thom Ritchie's Philip braised
frames soon follow
at the same time Charlie Cunningham was
developing the first lightweight
aluminum bikes his ideas including drop
style handlebars for off-road were
decades ahead of their time Kelley and
business partner Gary Fisher began
selling Ritchie built frames as mountain
bikes the name stuck even though their
trademark did that that many people get
to put words in the dictionary and we
did Ritchie frames were also the
inspiration for specialized Stumpf
jumpers the first mass-produced and mass
advertised mountain bikes it's not just
a new bicycle it's a whole new sport
competitors like Trek and Cannondale are
going oh my gosh if we don't do get into
this right now we're going to be left in
the dust soon millions were taking to
the trails and streets on these new
bikes the mountain bike put people on
bikes that had never ridden before by
the late 1980s motorcycle designs were
finding their way into bikes as well
the RockShox front suspension fork
debuted in 1989 full suspension and disc
brakes weren't far behind with machines
like the Gary Fisher rs1 today breeze is
still designing Breezer mountain bikes
and kelly recently published a book on
the origins of the sport
oh well it'd be 40 years this fall since
we started racing at repack and it was
really the racing that
heard everything else the race just
started us on this journey that we're
still on
[Music]
you